Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Orphan Black we met a new clone, learned
a lot more about Sarah’s life pre season
1 and the Helena Prolethean plot just got
really really creepy.
Let’s dedicate this video to the memory
of Ainsley.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
I’m doing weekly vids for Orphan Black Season
2, be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I know a lot of you in international countries
have to wait to watch it.
So these will just be here for you when you
need them.
So let’s break a leg and talk about our
Top 5 Moments, then I’ll do my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Art Finds The Proletheans.
It seems like everytime Art and Angela have
a scene together she invokes Beth.
She’s been trying to guilt him into resuming
the mystery of the clones and it looks like
she was successful.
Art will hopefully be able to save Helena.
Because Gracie seems like the only Prolethean
who’s not 100% committed to making Helena
the newest Sister Wife, I’m hoping she helps
Art get her out.
Number 4 - Allison falls off the Stage.
Poor Blood Ties was doomed before it ever
began.
I love how thematically the plot of the play
works so well with Allison’s real life Ainsley
Clone Club drama.
No surprise that she shotgunned all that booze
and pills.
Let me know if you thought she was going to
react like that on stage or if you thought
she would just pull some great performance
out of her butt.
Tatiana Maslany in real life would probably
have turned it into an Emmy winner.
It’s so surreal watching Allison perform
the play too.
It’s an actor Tatiana Maslany, peforming
a character, Allison, who’s performing a
play, Blood Ties.
And even though Allison was supposed to collapse
under the pressure.
The whole thing was just amazing.
We seriously need to make sure she wins that
Emmy this year.
Number 3 - Meeting The New Clone Jennifer
The body horror that was going on with the
Cosima Delphine story this week was almost
hard to watch.
Did you notice the way Cosima reacted when
they were dissecting Jennifer?
After all the tapes and the surgery it was
like she had to watch her own slow gruesome
death.
I love how good the show is at putting you
into their perspective.
I loved how she saw Jennifer being kept in
the dark and told Delphine to not be a bitch
and just tell her the truth no matter what.
In case you missed it too, they identified
that the source of the cancer, the growths,
was inside the Uterus.
It means that any of the clones that are infertile
potentially have growths that are spreading.
That includes Rachel, Cosima, Allison and
we’re not sure about Helena yet.
Jennifer was the first clone to exhibit symptoms,
even though we met Katja first.
In the timeline, she died three days before
the events in this episode.
Number 2 - The Proletheans Force Helena to
Marry Henrik
The show hasn’t been super clear on the
technicalities of a prolethean marriage.
But I’d bet Henrik has been bound to Multiple
Women.
In an episode where we had to watch Jennifer
degenerate and get dissected on a table, I
feel like this Helena plot was more disturbing.
Did anyone else scream at their TV when Henrik
was carrying her down that hallway?
I really do hope Gracie ends up helping her
escape.
Even if it’s not altruistic, I feel like
any help at all would be a blessing.
Speaking of which, it seems like based on
Henrik’s “instruments in the war for creation”
speech, the proletheans will be the crazy
group this season that will escalate things.
I feel like it’s easier to trust someone
like Leekie, because he’s operating from
a place of pure science, which is all about
reliability and precision.
He’s evil, but you can predict what he might
do because he’s coming from a place of logic.
The Proletheans on the other hand seem like
they bend situations to suit their needs and
“as long as you do it in God’s name”,
anything goes.
So they will be starting some fires.
Keep your eyes peeled on them.
And my number 1 moment - Meet Cal, Your Dad.
Did anyone else have a second where they just
thought of Daario.
Once he and Sarah started to work through
their relationship and the WTF reveal of Kira
being his daughter, I really enjoyed his character.
It’s a little strange hearing him with an
American accent, but I can’t wait to see
where his story goes.
I’m guessing he’ll just stay part of the
Sarah plot.
But every once and a while different clones
stories will overlap.
So we could get some Cal Alison scenes or
Cal and Cosima depending on where the season
goes.
I really do expect him to rub off on Kira.
She seems so intuitive that she’s almost
like a fully grown adult just walking around
in a child’s body.
Did anyone else expect him to be a deadshot
with that rifle and just kill Daniel?
Until that whole car crash I kind of thought
her story would get folded into Cosima’s
back at the lab.
We saw a bunch of Mrs. S scenes in the teaser
for episode 4, so I wonder if it was her that
crashed into their car?
But let me know what your biggest WTF moment
was in the episode.
And who your favorite Clone was.
It’s hard to pick between Cal being Kira’s
father and Helena being abused by the proletheans.
But my favorite clone was definitely Jennifer.
May she rest in peace.
Overall I gave the episode an A minus for
doing such a good job of introducing this
new Cal wrinkle to the plot.
I don’t know how many episodes he’s in,
but let’s hope he survives to season 3.
The good thing about Orphan Black and his
other show Game of Thrones, is that they don’t
shoot at the same time.
So even though he was upgraded to cast regular
for season 5 of Game of Thrones, he can still
film episodes of Orphan Black season 3 if
it gets renewed.
Speaking of actors, I’m sure we’re all
in agreement that Tatiana Maslany is a goddess,
but just thinking about all the nuances she
brings to each of the different clones is
mind boggling.
And every time we meet a new clone she always
surprises me.
I feel like if you asked her too she could
just sit in a room and do all the clones having
a conversation with themselves, just seamlessly
jumping in and out of different characters.
Like a one-person clone club stage play.
Blood Ties style.
Allison needs to take some notes.
I’ve gotten so invested in the moment of
each new episode that I keep forgetting about
the overplot, the Project LEDA mystery and
Leekie and the Proletheans endgame.
Are we even sure what the Proletheans would
do with another Kira if Helena really could
get pregnant?
We know Leekie is trying to patent human DNA,
they’re just a mega corporation trying to
get rich.
Even if the Proletheans don’t care about
money it seems like their end result is the
same.
Just a bunch of homogenized humans made in
whatever they consider to be their perfect
image.
I wonder if in their scenario everyone on
the planet would get married to each other
in one huge creepy binding ceremony.
Yikes.
Let me know what you’re final thoughts are
on the episode.
I totally loved the new characters they introduced.
I can’t wait to see what they do with Daario
on the show.
So my next Orphan Black video will post after
episode 4 next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Tomorrow is all about Game of Thrones as usual.
Right now click here for last week’s Orphan
Black video and click here to catch up on
Game Of Thrones.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!